[Música]
ucrania se prepara para nuevos ataques
de rusia en la región del donbass en el
este del país y donde se han fortalecido
las tropas del kremlin desde su retirada
de kiev el canciller de austria advirtió
de un ataque a gran escala tras su
reunión con vladimir putin
a menos de dos semanas de la segunda
vuelta en francia los candidatos inician
una feroz campaña por la presidencia la
pregunta es a dónde irán los votos del
candidato que quedó en tercer lugar
jong wook mélenchon quien le dijo a sus
seguidores que no voten por leppel pero
no apoyó directamente a matrona
en estados unidos el presidente joe
biden anunció nuevas regulaciones para
controlar las llamadas armas fantasma
como se les conoce a las armas de fuego
ensambladas a partir de piezas sueltas y
que no cuentan con número de serie por
lo que es difícil rastrear las en
investigaciones criminales ampliados
desde washington
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz empezamos en ucrania
que se prepara para una nueva fase de la
invasión rusa con la ofensiva en la
región del donbass el temor fue
confirmado por el canciller de austria
carne jaime quien visitó moscú para
reunirse con el presidente ruso vladimir
putin y pedir el fin de su invasión a
ucrania pero el encuentro no fue nada
productivo según dijo desde que las
tropas enviadas por moscú comenzaron su
repliegue en kiev han concentrado su
fuerza militar en la región del donbass
y los combates se han enfocado con más
fuerza de mariupol las autoridades
ucranianas sostienen que al menos un 90
por ciento de esta ciudad portuaria está
destruida maría clara calle con los
detalles
calles desoladas mientras ucrania se
prepara para un ataque inminente en la
región del donbass
el ejército ucraniano está listo no
podemos predecir cuándo sucederá
exactamente tenemos información de
fuentes occidentales dicho esto el
enemigo casi ha terminado la preparación
para la operación ofensiva de disney
vuestras tanto quiere como washington
han hecho la advertencia desde hace más
de una semana mientras que las tropas de
moscú se han fortalecido en el este tras
su retirada de la región de kiev así se
ha visto en ataques como el de la
estación de tren de crematorio o con
tanques recorriendo las calles de bolt
novak a los combates se concentran en
mariupol la capital de facto del huv las
de donges separatistas respaldados por
rusia señalaron que la ciudad portuaria
es uno de los principales objetivos
militares
el punto más candente sigue siendo
mariupol donde el enemigo ha concentrado
sus fuerzas en empresas industriales
el estado mayor general de las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas afirma que rusia está
intentando tomar el control de mariupol
mientras que el presidente mencionó a la
urbe para pedirle armas a corea del sur
dice aquí mariupol está destruida hay
decenas de miles de muertos pero aún así
los rusos no detienen la ofensiva
quieren hacer de mariupol un ejemplo que
puede dar software en el bus pocas
ocasiones ni tienen mismo
moscú por su parte sostiene que no
parará sus operaciones militares para
sentarse a negociar como dicen que sí lo
hicieron en la primera ronda de
conversaciones
después de que nos convencimos de que
los ucranianos no planeaban corresponder
se tomó la decisión de que durante las
próximas rondas de conversaciones no
habría pausa militar mientras no se
firme un acuerdo final
moscú acusa a occidente de querer dañar
las conversaciones mientras refuerza su
presencia militar en el este de ucrania
en francia empezó una feroz campaña por
la presidencia de cara a la segunda
vuelta en la que se enfrentan el
presidente de manuel macro ni la
candidata de extrema derecha marine
lepén para ser acusado por sus oponentes
de ignorar la elección por la crisis en
ucrania el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón se fue directo a los seguidores
de marín lepén con un acto en la ciudad
de lille y según estimaciones de ipsos
sobras steria para france24 el
presidente obtendría un 54% de apoyo
frente al 46% del epp en los aspirantes
derrotados ya han empezado a pedir a sus
seguidores por quién votar
el líder izquierdista jean luc mélenchon
quedó en tercer lugar y estuvo a punto
de liderar el conteo junto con macrón y
evitar que se repitiera la segunda
vuelta de 2017 sus partidarios están
sintiendo tristeza poselectoral más
detalles en el siguiente informe
al día siguiente en la ciudad de
marsella donde el candidato de
izquierdas onic meloso encabezó los
resultados como un 31% la decepción es
palpable y hitman culé externa máncora
estoy muy enfadado muy enfadado estamos
en una situación catastrófica en este
país algunas personas no han elegido una
voz para el progreso y la solidaridad
estoy extremadamente decepcionada lo
esperaba un poco pero tenía muchas
esperanzas de que los márgenes eran muy
estrechos así que estoy muy decepcionado
en la región de parís - un también quedó
en primer lugar y algunos votantes se
han sentido desilusionados y eso posee
luego ayer pensábamos que ella luc
mélenchon iba a estar en la segunda
vuelta y que sería nuestro nuevo líder
pero no es así lo superaremos pero es
cierto que estamos un poco perdidos a
casi 7.000 kilómetros de distancia en
guadalupe hubo conmoción cuando se
anunciaron los resultados porque me lo
había obtenido más de la mitad de los
votos en la isla no estamos
representados en los resultados
nacionales no nos sentimos escuchados y
es una verdadera pena es una gran
decepción para nosotros el domingo por
la noche en parís estos votantes de
mirón salieron a la calle para expresar
su oposición a marín lópez serán clave
para saber quién se convierte en
presidente en la segunda vuelta
electoral
muchos están indecisos prefiero quedarme
bajo mi edredón y evitarlo todo no
saldré a votar de nuevo no tiene sentido
uno u otro son lo mismo los votos
cruciales de menos aún podrían ir a
cualquiera de los dos candidatos en
otras noticias pakistán tiene un nuevo
primer ministro
se trata de chivas sheriff quien prestó
juramento después de haber sido elegido
por el parlamento y en reemplazo de irra
mccann quien fue destituido este sábado
tras aprobarse una moción de confianza
en su contra con la llegada de sharif
amigo de occidente el nuevo gobierno
podría cambiar la diplomacia con países
como rusia china y eeuu es que el
antiguo premier no solo intentó
acercarse a moscú sino que además acusó
a washington de respaldar su
derrocamiento
pasamos a eeuu al presidente joe biden
anunció nuevas regulaciones para
controlar las llamadas armas fantasma
así se le conoce a las armas de fuego
ensambladas a partir de piezas sueltas
que no cuentan con un número de serie y
por ende no pueden ser rastreadas estas
armas han aparecido en cantidades
mayores en escenas del crimen en todo el
país desde washington nuestro
corresponsal cristóbal vázquez nos envió
el siguiente reporte el departamento de
justicia revela que entre el 2016 y el
2020 la policía recuperó casi 24 mil
armas fantasmas en los lugares del
crimen alrededor de eeuu un problema que
empezó a preocupar a las autoridades
después de que seis personas murieran en
santa mónica california tras ser
baleadas por un hombre con un arma
fantasma estas armas no tienen número de
identificación porque son ensambladas
por partes que se compran separadamente
en el mercado sin embargo hoy yo baiden
desde la casa blanca dijo que en 120
días los distribuidores de estas armas
tendrán que empezar a ponerle el número
de identificación no solamente a ésta
sino también a las partes de estas armas
antes de poderlas vender esto permitirá
si entonces a las autoridades rastrear
las armas que son encontradas o
confiscadas en las escenas del crimen
sin embargo organizaciones como gun
owners of america prometió ya que
lucharía inmediatamente contra el
decreto y que demandará a la oficina de
armas explosivos tabaco y alcohol de
eeuu para detener la implementación de
esta medida
en méxico el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador celebró lo que calificó
como un éxito en el resultado de la
consulta de revocación de su mandato y
que fue impulsada por el mismo de
acuerdo con cifras del instituto
nacional electoral a más del 90 por
ciento de los votantes decidió que ambos
siguiera en la presidencia sin embargo
la jornada contó con una muy baja
participación sólo el 17 72 por ciento
por lo que la consulta no es vinculante
ya que no alcanzó el 40 por ciento que
se necesita
transportistas mexicanos bloquearon el
puente internacional reynosa pharr que
une a la ciudad mexicana de reynosa con
el estado de texas y el principal acceso
de productos agrícolas a eeuu una larga
hilera de camiones se dejó ver en la
carretera sus conductores se quejan de
las extensas revisiones a las que son
sometidos por parte de las autoridades
estadounidenses y las que pueden tardar
hasta tres días lo que afecta gravemente
el envío de productos frescos que salen
del lado mexicano
de esta manera despedimos este
informativo en france 24 pero los
invitamos a visitar nuestra página web
www france24 puntocom para seguir la
actualización de nuestras noticias
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]